a federal prosecutor from Chicago is now
in charge of turning over subpoenaed
Justice Department documents to
congressional committees investigating
alleged bias against President Trump it
is the latest move and what has been a
highly contentious process tonight we
welcome the US attorney in charge of
this John louse thanks for being here
thanks happy to be here thank you let's
start by asking you where are we now
how many of these documents have been
turned over okay so there's there's
there's a handful of documents have been
turned over there's there's several
thousand pages but I think the key at
this point is really identifying you
know what additional relevant
information is out there turning it over
as quickly as we can and doing so as
completely as we can given the legal
obligations that exist and there are
certain legal obligations that we have
as prosecutors which prevent us
providing some documents like grand jury
material things like that
but that's really where we're at in the
process what is the total scope of what
you're looking at how many total
documents okay so and there's been some
kind of misinformed about the documents
that are out there one of the numbers
that's out there is I think 1.2 million
and that's the entire universe of
materials that went to the inspector
general but the number of relevant
documents is going to be much less than
that how much less than that I I don't
know I'm I anticipate a lot less than
that for various reasons but you know
one of my job's is to figure out what
are those relevant documents to work
with the people that are reviewing them
now and to ensure that we get them
produced as quickly as we can chairman
goodlet basically asked for everything
the IG was given from the FBI right well
what the IG was given from the FBI as it
relates Clinton to the Clinton matter
exactly all right so our Justice
Department seducer tells me that sources
familiar with this this process say if
you look at the the Clinton
investigation the number goes down from
1.2 million to about 400,000 is that
right it goes down a lot less I'm not
prepared to say what that number is yet
I'm just getting started
but I think it goes down substantive
ASIC word searches it goes down even
right that's a man that's the hope is
really figure out the way to identify
the most relevant materials as quickly
as we can to get Congress what it's
entitled to so they can do their jf bi
director Chris Rea said on March 27th
I'm doubling the number of assigned FBI
staff for a total of 54 to cover two
shifts per day from 8 a.m. to midnight
to expedite completion of this project
it is April 10th 15 days later you have
Capitol Hill up in arms that they can't
get these documents there's frustration
up there there's frustration from the
president what is taking so long
right so I mean based on my experience
both as a prosecutor then a private
practice beforehand I mean document
review is they can just take time and
one of the reasons that they take some
time is you know can reviewing all the
materials to look for relevance but then
to figure out what what materials need
to be redacted out of there and so the
additional folks that have been added is
going to be helpful right I mean you
understand this process has been going
on right long time right up until you
right
all right here's trey gowdy up on
Capitol Hill if there's a national
security issue we want it redacted but
most of what they send us now looks like
an inkblot test I want to be able to
support the FBI and DOJ but the world's
premier law enforcement agency can't
seem to operate a damn copying machine
we are tired of being patient so you
hear that frustration right yeah
absolutely I think that's one of the
reasons why I'm here is is to address
that specific frustration I look forward
to meeting the congressman tomorrow I've
met some other congressmen today in
order to deal with exactly that issue I
think the redaction issue is an issue
that we just need to confront head-on
and talk about why certain things are
redacted and find a way to give them
faith that what they're getting is is
the right information and if there are
redactions there to explain what that is
and and and and why they're not entitled
to receive it right and the president's
tweet is what does the Department of
Justice the FBI have to hide why aren't
they giving the strongly requested
documents unredacted to the House
Judiciary Committee stalling but for
what reason not looking good have you
heard from the White House on this issue
I have not
not earlier today I mean I met with the
Attorney General I'm not the Deputy
Attorney General I'm up the general
counsel of the FBI it's it's very clear
that my direction is to ensure that we
get the documents produced as quickly as
we can we do so completely under under
the laws and we do so with integrity and
professionalism do you look at the
substance of those documents as far as
they're there I mean as a prosecutor
well I mean I as far as my job my job I
think is gonna be a lot about process
part of which will be the redactions
right and we're going to want to give
them as much as we can't save it
Congress is a very important job to do
here and we want them to do that we need
them to look at these documents and in
order to do their job so we'll look at
the substance in order to determine are
the redactions appropriate lastly do you
have any indication when the IG is going
to come forward with his report I do not
but do you expect it before you finish
the process of getting documents up to
Capitol Hill I don't know the answer to
that well listen we appreciate the
answers that you have been able to
provide and thanks for the time right
thanks for having me okay